welcome back everyone look at that
dinosaurs are taking over downtown las
vegas
it's a brand new attraction with dozens
of life-sized dinosaurs and those are
supposed to be there
hector mejia is there for us with a lot
you know i've never seen a real dinosaur
but i'm told these are just like the
real thing
take a look this is one of 65
animatronic dinosaurs on display here at
the pavilion parking lot
we're at the world market center and if
you've driven by the i-15 spaghetti bowl
chances are
you've seen this from your car you're
wondering what is it well this is part
of the new attraction and joining us
this afternoon
we have david who is general manager
here at jurassic empire
all right so it's the last weekend for
you guys here it is our last weekend
here we do have this dinosaur
drive-through where you get to
experience it from the comfort of your
vehicle
up close and personal so once you get
here
you are driving through a zoo of
dinosaur which is probably
jurassic and david jurassic what's the
reaction you get from kids when they see
these for the first time most of them
are scared most of them are excited but
everybody is happy at the end of by then
when they leave
um tell us you know how many do you guys
have 60 we have 65 life-size dinosaurs
here
and they're all moving roaring and
breathing
we will be open this weekend which is
our last weekend friday from 1 p.m to 9
p.m
saturday and sunday 9 a.m to 9 p.m and
for all general information and
questions please visit
www.jurassicempire.com
what's the price range for the entrance
fee oh we have 59
on the weekday um it will be from one to
seven passengers
and 69 on the weekend with one to seven
passengers it's like dinosaurs took over
las vegas awesome
absolutely thank you for having me not a
problem we'll be posting all of those
details on our website aytonsnow.com
reporting from downtown las vegas hector
mejia
8 news now back to you